la dernière vidéo sur le stoïcisme vous
a beaucoup plu manifestement et je me
suis dit que ce serait pas mal de
traiter son son pendant son concurrent
appelez ça comme vous voulez qu'on
appelle l'épicurisme donc épicurisme qui
est dérivé du nom des piqûres qui était
le maître le fondateur de cette école de
pensée
alors comme avec le stoïcisme il existe
des des dizaines de porte d'entrée à
cette pensée est mon objectif dans cette
vidéo n'est évidemment par deux proposé
un exposé exhaustif sur sur cette
philosophie est plutôt de vous donner
des pistes de réflexion à partir
desquels vous pourrez partager vos
propres recherches
alors déjà on va se débarrasser d'un
petit lieu commun qui traîne
je pense que les gens qui se sont un peu
intéressée à l'épicurisme connaissent
bien ce lieu commun qui est de dire que
l'épicurisme ce serait où se réduire et
plutôt à une philosophie de la
jouissance entendit je suis un épicurien
ça veut dire j'aime les plaisirs de la
vie les plaisirs de la chair les
plaisirs terrestres
ça c'est facile de justifier par exemple
la gourmandise ou le penchant à l'alcool
voire aux drogues
c'est aussi assez facile de justifier
son penchant à la chair ce que les
chrétiens appellent la luxure en se
réclamant de la philosophie d'epicure
donc ça c'est un lieu commun dont on
veut se débarrasser très vite puisqu'en
fait epicure explique que le bonheur ne
peut pas être atteint dans l'excès pour
epicure certes nous sommes des êtres de
chair
nous avons un corps et en vertu de ce
corps nous éprouvons des sensations
ces sensations elle s'éprouve entre deux
intervalles pourrait dire de repères qui
sont le plaisir et la douleur alors des
plaisirs il en existe de toutes sortes
et la douleur également mais disons que
d'une manière générale on peut ranger
nos sensations dans ces deux catégories
plaisir douleur l'homme aspire
naturellement au plaisir c'est à dire
que quand quelque chose lui procure une
sensation agréable il aura tendance à se
diriger vers cette chose et al'inverse à
fuir que ce qui sera source de déplaisir
tout ce qui sera source de douleur le
problème c'est que parfois l'homme se
trompent
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que souvent il prend pour un plaisir ce
qui constitue en fait davantage une
souffrance c'est un paradoxe messas
illustre très bien par des exemples
concrets alors tout à l'heure je parlais
du penchant à l'alcool boire un verre de
vin en boire un deuxième un troisième
finir la bouteille ça peut procurer
beaucoup de plaisir sont tous si c'est
du bon vin ça peut nous rendre heureux
sur le moment il ya des gens qui ne
boivent pas mais vous pouvez associer sa
à une autre forme de gourmandise on peut
par exemple vouloir finir le pot de
nutella
alors qu'on vient de l'année ça procure
beaucoup de plaisir
mais le problème c'est que le lendemain
le plaisir va laisser sa place à la
douleur la gueule de bois pour l'alcool
la crise de foi comme on dit dans tous
les cas il y aura une conséquence
négative à ce plaisir
ce que dit epicure c'est que pour être
heureux il ne suffit pas de courir après
le plaisir il faut modérer le plaisir de
telle sorte qu'il ne soit que du plaisir
la philosophie d'epicure c'est d'abord
une philosophie de la modération
on peut appeler ça également une
philosophie de l' équilibre et si cet
équilibre est rompu
ça veut dire qu'on ne suit pas la voie
de la sagesse
on est dans une sorte de deux poursuites
immature d'un plaisir qu'on ne maîtrise
pas et qui du coup nous maîtrise
il n'y a pas de bonheur possible dans
l'excès le bonheur c'est la résultante
d'un comportement modérés pondéré
équilibré alors on sait que chez epicure
il y à une classification des désirs
petit rappel sémantique le désir n'est
pas le plaisir le plaisir c'est le
résultat de la satisfaction d'un désir
qu'est ce qu'un désir un désir c'est une
force intérieure qui nous pousse vers un
objet en vue de se l'approprier
alors faut savoir que quand on parle
d'objets en philosophie ça peut
s'appliquer à une personne désirée une
personne par exemple désirez avoir une
relation sexuelle avec quelqu'un ça veut
dire que la personne qu'on désire
devient l'objet de notre désir est donc
ce désir qui est une une force c'est
aussi un manque parce que on désire ce
qu'on n'a pas
et là on peut faire un petit parallèle
avec rousseau qui nous disait bien que
l'objet de notre désir cesse d'être
désiré sitôt qu'on obtient voilà
pourquoi rousseau penser que d'ailleurs
que le désir devait se suffire à
lui-même
c'était là la beauté du désir pour
lui-même mais peu importe donc le désir
n'est pas le plaisir le plaisir
c'est la conséquence de la satisfaction
d'un désir
j'obtiens l'objet que je désire j'en
éprouve du plaisir pur epicure il existe
300 de désir alors là ça va être un peu
plus scolaire ce que je vais dire mais
je pense que ça permettra aussi de
lancer quelques pistes
tout d'abord les désirs naturel et
nécessaire prenons des exemples
manger est un désir naturel et
nécessaire nécessaire à quoi à la survie
naturel pourquoi pas parce que c'est
dans notre essence biologique de nous
nourrir
donc la fin qui est un besoin se
manifeste sous le vêtement du désir
autrement dit je désire ce dont j'ai
besoin
respirer c'est un besoin alors est ce
que c'est un désir qu'on vous prive
qu'on vous prive d'oxygène vous allez
désiré respirer le désir sexuel alors le
désir sexuel je sais qu'il y en a qui
vont polémiquer en disant qu' on peut
très bien ne pas avoir de désir sexuel
c'est vrai le fait est que à l'échelle
de l'humanité si bien à l'échelle de
l'humanité
si nous n'avions pas de désir sexuel
l'humanité s'éteindrait donc l'humanité
a besoin de se reproduire pour se
perpétuer
c'est presque une tautologie que de le
dire
epicure nous dit que les désirs naturel
et nécessaire doivent être satisfaits on
n'a pas le choix donc pas de problème
pour ses désirs là viennent ensuite les
désirs naturel mais non nécessaire je
disais tout à l'heure que manger était
un désir naturel et nécessaire mais
manger une entrecôte avec une sauce au
poivre une sauce roquefort accompagné
d'un petit verre de pic saint loup
je défends ma région ben c'est naturel
pourquoi c'est naturel bas parce que sur
le plan gustatif c'est agréable et on a
dit tout à l'heure que l'homme
poursuivait naturellement ce qui lui
procurer du plaisir
est-ce que c'est nécessaire non c'est à
dire que je n'ai pas besoin de manger un
un mets raffiné pour me nourrir un
morceau de pain et une bouteille d'eau
peuvent très bien faire la ferme mais en
même temps j'en éprouve le désir
alors que faire eh bien et puis qu on
nous dit que ces désirs la lé désir
naturel et non nécessaires peuvent être
satisfaits avec modération
on rappelle que la modération
c'est la limitation dans la satisfaction
des désirs
vous connaissez le slogan à consommer
avec modération
un verre deux verres pas plus c'est un
peu ça l'idée
voilà pour les deuxièmes la deuxième
sorte la deuxième classe de désir
naturel et non nécessaire et enfin nous
avons la troisième catégorie des désirs
qui sont les désirs non naturelle et non
nécessaire exemple
manger une bonne entrecôte avec un bon
verre de vin dans une assiette en argent
ou avec des couverts ornée de pierres
précieuses
alors là pour epicure ça y est on a
franchi on a franchi la barre on a
franchi la limite ce sont des désirs 20
ce n'est ni naturelle ni nécessaire ce
n'est pas nécessaire mais ça je n'ai pas
besoin de vous réexpliquer pourquoi ce
n'est pas naturel nous dire les piqûres
pourquoi parce que c'est c'est
l'expression de ce qu'on pourrait
appeler avec un terme un peu barbare une
dégénérescence dégénérescence c'est à
dire que naturellement l'homme n'éprouve
pas besoin il éprouve ce besoin à partir
du moment où il y goûte et à partir du
moment où il ne parvient pas à maîtriser
ce désir ce désir mégalomaniaque
si vous préférez les désirs non
naturelle et non nécessaire témoigne
d'un dérèglement c'est une pathologie
est la meilleure preuve c'est que à
partir du moment où on franchit cette
limite des désirs non naturelle on tombe
dans l'addiction l'alcoolisme
encore une fois la toxicomanie qu'est ce
que c'est c'est augmenter les doses
progressivement pour retrouver cette
sensation initial qu'on ne peut plus
éprouvés à partir du moment où on
s'habitue au plaisir
donc on augmente les deux et donc on se
fait encore plus de mal
la philosophie d'epicure n'est pas une
philosophie de la jouissance sans
entrave la philosophie d'epicure est une
philosophie de la frugalité
c'est une philosophie de l'économie des
plaisirs on est vraiment dans cette
mentalité grec de la maîtrise de soi de
l' équilibre de la raison il faut savoir
que l'épicurisme a ouvert la voie à
l'utilitarisme qui est une philosophie
qui s'est développée principalement
xviiie siècle sous l'affluence de jeremy
bentham poursuivi par john stuart mill
qui ont pour ainsi dire lever la
barrière de la limitation des grecs
un savoir que chez les grecs il y avait
un terme pour désigner limitation des
désirs il appelait salut brice hybrid4
brice c'est quand le filtre saute c'est
quand l'homme où la femme
autre passe cette limitation naturel
dans la satisfaction des désirs qui fait
que potentiellement il peut désirer tout
et n'importe quoi et lorsqu'on observe
certains comportements pervers on peut
se dire que on est là face à des cas du
bri prenons un millionnaire a priori le
millionnaire sa survie et assurer la
survie de ces enfants est assuré
donc on peut dire que sur le plan
matériel il a fait son taf
individuellement et communautairement
mais à partir du moment où le
millionnaire nourrit le désir d'être
milliardaire
alors se pose légitimement la question
de sa motivation
qu'est ce qu'il vous faut
de quoi at il besoin qu'il n'ait pas
encore pu dire quand on est millionnaire
a priori d'oursin est bien celui qui est
dans un état du bri il ne dort pas
serein parce qu'il lui faut plus
toujours plus le capitalisme c'est une
doctrine qui valide le principe de
l'hubris puisqu'elle est basée sur le
dogme de la croissance infinie
si les piqûres était là peut-être ne
faisons pas parler des morts peut-être
dire et il vous est gouvernée par une
bande de malades a littéralement
littéralement on est bien dans le pathos
on est bien dans la pathologie on est
bien dans parce que pato ce passif un
sens c'est de là que vient le mot c'est
lorsqu'on subit et le millionnaire
voulant devenir milliardaire il est
victime de sa propre passion de sa
propre une brise de sa propre limitation
pour cet homme là la modération
c'est quelque chose qui a été oublié en
cours de route donc cet homme là aura
plus de mal à devenir sage alors je suis
pas dans le jugement
il ya aucune animosité un conte ce dix
ans et on peut rencontrer des
millionnaires et des milliardaires sans
doute très heureux l'idée
c'est que à partir du moment où on ne
maîtrise plus le désir mais où c'est lui
qui nous maîtrise on s'écarte de la voie
du bonheur on s'écarte de la voie de la
sagesse authentique dans une précédente
vidéo
je lisais un texte d'alexis de
tocqueville qui parlait des sociétés
démocratiques dans lesquelles il n'y a
plus de tirs ans parce qu'il n'y a plus
besoin de tyrans nous avons affaire à
des tuteurs à des gens qui nous guide et
qui nous pousse de manière plus ou moins
fines et rusé vers des choses qui nous
pousse à consentir à ces choses et on
sait qu'un peuple et gouvernable
d'autant plus gouvernable qu'il est
lui-même son propre maître
à partir du moment où on remplace la
domination sur les corps ce qui est le
principe de la tyrannie d'accord des
interdits des obligations à partir bon
on remplace système de domination par
l'idéologie du désir on n'a plus besoin
de contraindre on n'a plus besoin de
forcer on n'a qu'à laisser la masse
suivre ses désirs et si en plus de ça on
conditionne suffisamment bien cette
masse de citoyens pour lui faire désirer
des choses vaine selon la qualification
des piqûres on obtient un peuple soumis
soumis à ses propres désirs
il est évident qu'à partir du moment où
vous mettez le pied dans un centre
commercial
il sera beaucoup plus efficace pour le
système que vous obéit sied à vos
pulsions à vos désirs d'achat de
consommation c'est à quel point
l'acte d'achat d'un point de vue
psychologique traduit un manque ce que
uni cote appelé l' objet transitionnel
un l'enfant un doudou qui remplace la
mer et puis ensuite il va commencer à
vouloir des objets pour remplacer le
doudou des jouets et à partir du moment
où il grandit les jouets vont laisser
leur place à d'autres produits
la cigarette l'alcool etc etc
on est en plein coeur de ce don par les
piqûres l'hubris les limitations et le
désir de trouver à l'extérieur de soi
une satisfaction qu'on ne parvient pas à
obtenir à l'intérieur de soi
notre société n'est donc pas une société
épicurienne on en est assez loin notre
société ne l'aiment pas une société
utilitariste puisque l'utilitarisme
j'avais fait une petite parenthèse
l'utilitarisme certes considère que la
jouissance et constitue le tout de
l'existence
1 on est et on vit pour éprouver du
plaisir
mais malgré tout chez les utilitaristes
on trouve encore l'idée que parfois la
limitation dans ses désirs est
avantageuse on peut reprendre l'exemple
de la gueule de bois que je citais à
savoir que si je bois de l'alcool
j'aurai du plaisir mais le lendemain je
vais douillet
donc si je fais un petit calcul un
puisque l'homme est un être rationnel
disent les utilitaristes sont fait un
petit calcul on s'aperçoit que
aller chercher ces plaisirs c'est pas
forcément une bonne idée
donc on va s'auto dignité la société
moderne appelons la comme ça a fait
sauter le verrou de cette limitation et
vous verrez si ce n'est pas déjà le cas
à quel point la notion même de limite
est une notion disqualifié discrédité
dans certains pans de la société
c'est la limite en tant que limite qui
doit être aboli alors pourquoi pas
j'arrive parfaitement à comprendre que
l'entrepreneur que l'artiste que des
gens qui soient dans un processus d'
aventure soit hostile à la notion de
limite mais enfin à l'échelle à
l'échelle 10 ont collective qu est-ce qu
entraînerait l'abolition de toute limite
la jungle la jungle je fais partie de
ceux qui considèrent que à partir du
moment où on doit formuler une loi c'est
que la loi a été perdu ça veut dire qu'
elle n'est plus en nous on la formule on
l'a formalise on la met en forme
précisément pour qu' elle soit reconnue
et acceptée
ce serait parfait s'il n'y avait pas
besoin de loi
ce serait parfait si les êtres humains
s'autogouverner mais dans un système
dans un système où nous nous abandonnons
chaque jour notre souveraineté à des
dirigeants
la loi nécessaire parce qu'un enfant qui
grandit sans règle dans une société avec
des règles ça ne devient pas un être
libre
ça devient un petit con bon je me suis
écarté du sujet alors ça plaira
peut-être à certains - à d'autres mais
c'est pas grave je vous invite à lire la
lettre à ménécée des piqûres
parce que dans cette lettre
epicure expose sa vision du plaisir de
la douleur il expose sa vision morale il
expose également sa vision de la mort et
ça c'est un sujet très intéressant que
je n'ai pas traité dans cette vidéo
parce que je m'en occuperai plus tard on
va faire les choses étape par étape
en tout cas j'espère vous avoir donné
quelques éléments de réflexion
je vous remercie pour votre attention
à bientôt
[Musique]
et